welcome back to CBS morning's our next
guest host is one of the one and only
rather Marlon Wayans the comedian actor
has been performing stand-ups since he
was a teenager in a starred in dozens of
popular series of movies like scary
movie and white chicks he says in 2018
the Netflix special wokish was a career
Milestone here's a clip of him talking
about police shootings
something has to change and I think they
need a new check and balance system you
can't partner a potentially racist cop
with another potentially racist cop no
we need check and balance
so for every potentially racist cop well
partner him with a strong black female
officer
yes because sisters are firm but they
are fair and ain't gonna let no
Injustice happen that white cop get out
hand oh sister gonna check it and he has
a new HBO Max special that just dropped
called Marlon Wayans God loves me
somehow he has found the time to join us
before taking his turn at the desk as
the guest host of The Daily Show The
Daily Show airs on Comedy Central part
of Paramount Global Marlon Wayans joins
us this morning good morning thank you
thank you for being here so we we got it
he also chip her this early in the
morning because he's been doing this yes
we're excited to see you I'm always like
that you're going to learn it by the way
you could tell when they had the tacos
nachos out here you could tell which one
of y'all didn't eat breakfast because
you was getting down
so I got Ta all that
at home and sis was like as soon as I'm
out here we got breakfast
they were pretty good we'll look make
sure you try some before you go all
right for sure um but before we get to
The Daily Show and you guest hosting we
gotta ask I know you saw the Netflix
special with this rock of course awesome
what did you think because your Special
Touch is on
the incident that happened no he touched
on an incident to happen my special goes
deep dive yeah my whole thing is about
that
um I thought that you know Chris is
always a master of the stage you know
I've known Chris since I was like 11 12
years old so you know I um I always
respect his craft and you know coming up
he's always like a mentor or somebody
that I look to so you know just watching
them roam that stage like like a hungry
tiger is always great
um I really uh it was good to hear him
speak about it you could tell it was
passionate you know the last 10 minutes
you know he went in he went in and I was
like no that's what you get slapped for
um what I was saying was but see that
was what you've heard was somebody that
was hurt right and somebody that was
Finding their way to heal in that moment
now that we all said it right I did my
special that was about all of it because
from my perspective I know the three of
them right they're my friends and you
know I felt like I had to talk about it
because it affected my journey and
that's what God loves me is and I think
that now if I had it my way I would pull
the the three of them into the
principal's office and go we have to
stop this have you spoken to him about
it separately separately and I just you
know but as a friend like my my special
is with love right they are part of it
as you said a deep dive were they okay
with being a part of it in the world I
don't know I didn't call them
but everybody I know all my friends
because you know we all celebrities in
in Hollywood and black Hollywood you
know blackout was like black Twitter but
with suits on and so we're we're all
connected so I've had a lot of my
friends hit me up like yo that was
beautiful that was a great love letter
it was brilliant the way you touched on
everything it was fair but you was firm
and it was made with love and that's
what this special is you said though in
the past that you would hope that the
two men can reconcile do you still think
that that's possible given
he really did sound hurt at the end of
that special I think both of them are
hurt
um I don't think I think Will's hurt
it has nothing to do with Chris I think
maybe something has happened in Will's
life you know I mean that was a snap
moment that brother that brother snap
that's not will Will's composed you know
I mean there's only two brothers I know
that composed
Obama I was gonna say Obama comes to
mine it was the most composed Brothers
I'm like I don't know how y'all do that
but in that moment it was a snap I hoped
they could come together I mean I don't
think it's ever cool to hit somebody but
I do think that at some point we can't
let that just sit there you know I think
for our children I think for our people
I think for the people that we just
can't sit in pain and not come to terms
and I think we can all make mistakes but
at some point we're growing grown grown
behind men let's sit down and come to
the table let's fix this all right let's
talk about something you're doing on
purpose why slap all y'all and we'll
gladly take it I'll be happy to be
slapped by you anyway
look like a birthmark all right let's
talk about The Daily Show uh you've
never hosted a late night show before
right do I have that right yeah correct
I'm never never hold still late night
Showdown how are you prepping
um I don't know I'm used to answering
questions I'm not used to like you know
asking questions I'm not really that
interested you know I mean like I like
talking about me yeah so I don't know
how I'm gonna talk about a guest but I
am sitting here and I'm sorry
get that suit really there yeah that's
that's nice it goes on the inside yeah
that's a nice Florida shout out because
it got the way it's stiff real business
like I want to give you money I don't
know why yeah I just want to give you
some money for the breaking news
situation just in case I got to turn it
Marlin we got to hold it there and go
right to the camera uh I got a question
though so the you've never done late
night before are you gonna take a nap
between now and tonight because I woke
up and went to the gym this morning and
you know that's not answering go ahead
you're gonna go to the gym be up before
Dawn yeah and then do a comedy show at
night tonight yeah we're gonna have fun
that's what that's what we do man we
have fun life is a short journey and
I've learned you smile as much as you
can because tomorrow is not promised so
I'm gonna enjoy every moment of today
let me ask you about um comedy in
general uh you and your brother Sean you
both dressed up it's not good good give
it what can we expect from this week I'm
sorry no yeah you're doing a whole week
right y'all confuse me
he's still asking about The Daily Show I
just watched big suit do something a
little soup I don't know
Okay so
which one do I ask Sis okay but now what
you're saying right now I'm curious to
know
what can we expect from this week with
The Daily Show I don't know expect the
unexpected I'm just going to have fun
I'm not going to go in there and make
the Daily Show like the Marlin show The
Daily Show has been The Daily Show for I
don't know 20 something years and
um it's it's a staple and comedy and I'm
just gonna go on that show and have fun
and you know I trust the writers I I'ma
bring my flavor I'll put my stank on it
but for the most part I'm just gonna I'm
gonna have fun I'm not I'm Gonna Change
The Daily Show I'm not I'm hoping I
don't get the Daily Show canceled
they've had 35 hosts if I'm the one to
get them canceled damn no that's not
gonna happen would you take the job
though if they offered you the job as
the full-time host
be honest if I get one and be honest now
yeah I'm doing those suits in my
contract
a lot of people know you from White
Chicks and you've said that a movie like
that needs to be made again yes explain
people too damn sensitive this Society
has replaced laughs and comedy with
social media and worries like we are so
anxious about everything because all we
do is look at world problems and give
our our opinions with and we're hiding
behind we're not even ourselves we've
got Bots influencing us from other
countries and we're not just enjoying
each other anymore we have to learn to
laugh at each other life is about
laughter I want to live a comedy so the
darkest thing happened to me the first
thing I go what's funny about it the
sooner I get to laugh and the sooner I
get to healing and I just think that we
all need to be less sensitive that's a
lot of anxiety it's messing our kids up
and we just gotta go have some fun man
it's a short ride that's beautiful here
you can have the Blue Jays
in The Green Room yeah just handing
Marlin that jacket it's like a match
[Laughter]
wear this today
Welcome to The Daily Show
I'm your host in the spirit of God being
sentenced beautiful I'm not going to be
sensitive to it so wait let me just ask
you yeah it's been a long way from Don't
Be a Menace to South Central While
Drinking Your Juice in the Hood sure
this Nike film air with Ben Affleck but
you've been in a lot of things you've
been in GI Joe
what is it like to be in this new movies
in the last like not in the jacket 37
seconds it's not in the jacket it's in
the hair yeah I can take this off as
well go ahead ask us a question ask us
any question you're interviewing us now
um why they didn't give you one of his
jackets
these guys
did you guys see
um the Michael B Jordan and what's
called and it's Jonathan Majors yeah
Jonathan Majors how did that go how did
that go for you
I would probably do the same thing they
they used their eyes you know what
people don't I just want to see who the
interviewer was that's what I missed out
on Instagram they did yeah I got to get
on Instagram pull up the clip this is
what my news will be pull up the clip
never mind the war on Ukraine we gotta
talk about something important here if
you're wondering who was the girl who
Marley Jordan and them this is why
you're tuning in to the Daily Show oh we
allegedly looked right now
we don't know for sure on the HBO math
special called Marlon Wayans remember
God loves me
um and right now though you can catch
Marlon guest hosting the Daily Show on
Comedy and all week